[Musik]
ihr seid schon echt krass weise genau
vor einer schar lautlos ist heute vor
einer woche habe ich an die auf meinem
kanal hochgeladen
ich weiß ist er aus der ju sieben tage
habe ich ein video hochgeladen
das ist wirklich etwas was ich sonst nie
tour in dem video habe ich mir selbst
beziehungsweise uns selbst als community
als luxury aufgabe gestellt schaffen die
es einem neuen kanal innerhalb von
sieben tagen auf 100 das sind 10 auf 100
tausend abonnenten zu bringen
everyday wollte man bei neue stativ hier
sehen cool oder auch die werden bei
diesem video das ich mir vernünftige
stativ kaufen kann
ich glaube sagt reden jetzt schafft
diese gerade halb von einer woche auf
100000 ende zu bringen dann besorge ich
uns diesen silbernen play button
den bekommt man halt bei 100000 und
diese vattenfall los hätte ich dann
soweit er keine medien zu hause
angekommen ist an euch als er einer von
euch hat die chance diesen silbernen
play button zu gewinnen der abonnent von
dem kanal ist weil sie den youtube kanal
also noch nicht abonniert habe findet
ihr nicht und in der beschreibung oder
könnte hier oben klicken der irgendwo da
könnt ihr den brauch abonnieren auf
jeden fall mit 100000 abonnenten jetzt
nicht erst nach wegen die sieben tage
reise oder ein zwei tagen oder sondern
dass drei stunden sind die komplett
wahnsinnig da hat nicht mal vier stunden
drei stunden paar minuten hat es
gedauert dass hunderttausend leute einen
kanal abonniert haben auf dem nur dieses
video bisher online vater
[Musik]
mein name ist luca ich bin blöd herzlich
willkommen auf einem kanal
falls sie schon hier seid lasst doch
gern aber da haben mir meinen kanal
abonnieren werdet dann wird
und wir werden die richtige it community
auf der welt auf jeden fall schon etwas
zusammenbraut wir uns den himmel plate
schon das ist übrigens 295 schreibtisch
dann würde es auch ein video auf dem
youtube kanal hochgeladen wie diese
schreibtische zusammengebaut haben kunst
youtube silbernen update button unsere
youtuber unser ganzer stolz blablabla
selber creator wird okay so erhält zu
deinem wort so weiter internet einnahmen
voraussetzungen erfüllt hat wird von uns
benachrichtigt und erhalten das heißt
wieder okay wir können uns da jetzt
anmelden luxurious 234 gmail.com
business adresse besteht keine
verbindung
oder der rivalisierende ja immer dafür
plädiert corporate relations switching
des majors sklavenmeister und danke new
deal immer der audienz not like to
deliver dort vorne die jetzt traktion
bis heit sowie can get cent autobahn
sind der krieg und button denen ich
direkt an euch weiter verschicke dazu
geht es dann endlich auch identischen
kopien hallo fokus da steht es soll
schon bekommen haben ich habe die
benachrichtigung mich gesteht dass man
oben im papers oder nachts bekommen von
wegen congratulations für deine
abonnenten
ich hab das nicht ich hab die keine auch
klassische geld ist ja mit dem kanal
verdienen vielleicht liegt es auch daran
vielleicht wirklich daran als ich da
keine werbung schaltet also ich erfülle
ja ganz klar die voraussetzungen hier
wirklich nicht so eine nachricht auf
gestellte fragen von creature wort wende
erst von höchstens einer woche die
erforderliche abonnentenzahl erreicht
hast du wird wahrscheinlich noch
überprüft ob dem kanal die voraussetzung
für den halter des skater whatsapp bild
sind die so langsam bei youtube.com
darüber 100.000 abonnenten jedoch habe
ich noch nichts mehr nachrichten für den
silber award bekommen warum hier meine
kaum habe ich dann den link reingepackt
krise danke liebe grüße lobby wichtig
jetzt mal auf senden und schauen was
youtube antwortet 2000 jahre später hier
steht auch einfach dass er mir dann
alles für den normalen ausgefüllt hat so
erhält seine bot dann innerhalb von
sechs bis zehn wochen den ganzen tag
zeit also das ganze mal kurz
zusammenzufassen also ich meine wer bis
jetzt geguckt hat ja alles mitbekommen
ich habe einfach spaß am kanal erstellt
um einfach zuschauen haley schnell
schaffen 400.000 moment auf diesem kanal
anscheinend innerhalb von drei stunden
also ich ziemlich schnell die
versprechen eine 200.000 abonnenten und
sie können den der silver age award von
youtube bekommen das dauert allerdings
noch ein bisschen weil wir ziemlich
schnell mal 1100 erreicht haben und wenn
ich ihn dann bestellen kann dann dort
auch mal zehn wochen bis er hier ist an
der stelle schon mal kein danke an
youtube frage
doch auf gestellt bekomme ist einfach
herr luca wovon nutzt du den kanal jetzt
eigentlich stehe ich werde den kanal
erstmal weitere ein bis zwei minuten
lange kurze bescheuerte blogs und videos
nutzen beispiel heute 1000 video
hochgeladen
wir haben die möbelmesse waren und ich
meine das video gegen halt eine minute
34 so das ist einfach eine zeit die ich
nie auf meinen hauptkanal opladen
dafür ist dieser kanal eigentlich
ziemlich gut von dem wohlig auch einige
wochen so richtig endlich mal wirklich
mit livestreams anfang also entweder
hier auf youtube ging die fragen
beantworten reactions et cetera oder
halt oft witsch und davon dann halt
irgendwie best-of highlights
zusammenschnitte auf dem kanal haben wie
das halt in amerika und jetzt auch in
deutschland immer mehr in mode über
machen und sich doch dafür ist der kanal
einfach ganz gut dann habe ich quasi
mein hauptkanal contractor luca auf dem
ich dann halt jeden tag ein video
hochladen durch mir wirklich mühe bei
gebe oft sind die videos halt aber
trotzdem voll beschlossen dass stimmen
und auf diesem lokal wenn ich mir dann
einfach noch weniger mühe geben ja eine
sache die mir allerdings auch
aufgefallen das ist wenn man einfach mal
luft uhr in der youtube suche eigentlich
da gibt es tatsächlich auch einige
kanäle von david vor mir angezeigt dass
erstmal ein kanal mit 155.000 blenden
und der kanal er mehr videos als 1300
aber nicht einfach eins zu eins meine
videos runter und lädt die welt sich
hoch und macht damit fast 10.000 aufrufe
also solche accounts können wir direkt
blocken weil er ist auf luxus das sind
einfach die uploads ihr auch es gibt
viele leute die einfach meine videos
kopieren den kanal kopiert und da meine
videos kopierte hochladen
da steht ihr was ich meine
90 hey ich bin gerade im schnitt von dem
video und habe mir jetzt an der stelle
gerade noch mal gedacht hey bevor ich
jetzt irgendwie kanäle hier im video
erwähne von wegen hin glaube meine
sachen und schaue ich dann noch vorbei
nicht dass sie wirklich beste ausmachen
und wein vorbeischauen habe ich dieses
wiederentdeckt luca hat sich 100.000
abonnenten gekauft da schauen wir doch
mal zusammen eben kurz rein allein
erstmal schon mal 69 likes und 500er hat
3700 abonnenten lädt aber täglich
mehrere videos hoch immer nur zu mir und
anderen youtube andré guter content der
kleine junge namens jonas möchte also
alles aufdecken möchte beweisen dass
alles fake ist ich bin gespannt auf das
video war alles gekauft jonas also das
video habe stattgefunden als ich einfach
nur zu feiern gegeben habe weil ich noch
mal nachschauen wollte heldt nicht dass
ich jetzt die kanäle die irgendwie
fertig machen und sagen ihr ladet
normale videos hoch aber die kopieren
halt wirklich nochmal eine videos also
ich dachte dass da zumindest irgendwie
pennartz drin werden oder irgendwelche
schnitten das ist einfach 11 mein video
gewesen ich fasse an der stelle
dass ich diesen jonas aufmerksamkeit
geben dieses video also man merkt es hat
halt irgendwie 546 like oder so aber
habe ich menschen nicht gesehen ziemlich
abstoßend und jetzt spielt weiter im
video übrigens kurz im titel wir haben
geschichte geschrieben
keine ahnung ob schon mal schneller in
deutschland 100.000 abonnenten erreicht
hat aber falls ja habe ich geschichte
für mich selbst geschrieben ich habe
noch nie so schnell 100 tausend
abonnenten ich das heute wieder beende
meine dicken zuschauer
ich habe mir gesagt einfach mal eine
woche alt dieses video hochladen wo ich
euch gesagt habe hersteller einen neuen
kanal wie schnell schaffen 100.000
abonnenten bei dem kanal also wir
wirklich sehr sehr schnell geschafft
also applaus am häufigsten video das
versprochene update der ganzen situation
also was ist mit dem silver trader
erwartet
das dauert noch ein bisschen ich werde
mich darum kümmern dass wir die so
schnell wie möglich bekommen und ihr
denen dann gewinnen können als wir
gewinnen könnt aber mir den luxus kanal
des und in der beschreibung damit jetzt
nicht stillgelegt oder so sondern nicht
wenn da wirklich weiterhin alle zwei
drei tage ein video hochladen und sich
nächsten halt auch beste aufs viele
schritte ezb als die sich auf jeden fall
aktiv sein schaut mal vorbei und jetzt
ist das video vorbei jetzt meine aus
[Musik]